it's great to be joined today by Beth
Macey who is the best-selling author of
dopesick dealers doctors and the drug
company that addicted America Beth it's
so great to talk to you today I think
maybe to start with some in our audience
may not know that although now the
opioid crisis is getting more attention
than it has maybe five ten years ago
this is not a particularly new problem
how long has this been a building
problem in the u.s. well I take it back
to the mid 1990s in my book so we're now
looking at over two decades I trace it
to the beginning of this movement that
pain was allegedly a fifth vital sign
and there was undertreated pain we had
this epidemic of undertreated pain and
in particularly I traced it to the
introduction of oxycontin an opioid
painkiller that Purdue Pharma introduced
in 1996 that was ballyhooed as being
safe to take addiction was allegedly
less than 1/2 of 1% addiction was quote
exquisitely rare and it was really that
drug that nationalized the supply and
eventually led to the heroin epidemic
can you talk a little bit about the ways
in which this epidemic is different than
others in terms of the communities
disproportionately affected and and why
that seems to be different yeah so
unlike a lot of prior epidemics which
began in the cities and then kind of
went out from there this epidemic takes
you know really erupts in distressed
rool marginalized communities where
factories were closing where coal mines
were shutting now my first book factory
man is actually about the aftermath of
globalization in one community where all
the textiles and furniture plants had
shut down and it didn't in that book
came out in 14 but we didn't know until
2016 that that community I wrote about
was actually the number one prescribing
place for
boys in the nation the small little town
in Martinsville Virginia so it took the
media a while to put the story together
as well as public health officials and
leaders and one of the reasons that it
erupts first in rural distressed
communities was because Purdue Pharma
hired an army of reps and then they
bought prescribing data that showed them
which places in the country already
prescribed the most competing opioids
and then they sent those reps out to
these kind of dying towns that had high
places high incidences of workplace
injuries and they went to those doctors
who are already prescribing opioids for
those and said look our drug is time
release that means that it is less
likely to lead to abuse and addiction
when in fact it was every bit in fact it
was more likely to lead to abuse
addiction because it had been it was a
stronger drug than the competing vicodin
lortab and other immediate-release
opioids but the FDA allowed them to make
this squishy claim that their brand new
time release mechanism made it less
likely to lead to abuse but if you go
back and you talk to the people in those
rural communities I mean even the cops
there knew almost right away that people
quickly figured out and run around that
time release mechanism they would put it
in their mouths they let the coating
melt off and then they will wipe it on
their sleeve and one cop told me you
could see people walking around with
orange and green stains on their
shirtsleeves and from where they had
done that that was the orange was the
forty in the green I believe was the 80
milligram and then they started
committing crimes because then once they
got hooked not only were they had to get
the drug in order not to be dope sick
and then but also people who weren't
hooked started seeing it as a way to pay
the bills they had lost their jobs they
could get their neighbor to get to get
their doctor to write right on my
prescription for oxycontin and then sell
them half I mean they were going on the
street for a dollar milligram for people
who don't know the pathway
from prescription opioids to heroin is
one that is a big factor in addiction
can you talk a little bit about how that
sort of works how does someone go from
going into a medical office and being
prescribed painkillers to buying heroin
on the street right so the pills got
expensive and well oxycontin became
reformulated finally in 2010 14 years
after it came out even though people
have been begging them to reformulate it
almost since the beginning so it gets
reformulated the government starts
getting concerned things like
hydrocodone get up schedule so they get
harder to get I eat more expensive and
the cartels are looking at hey they're
beginning to legalize marijuana in some
states what can we bring in and sell and
people are really gonna want to buy and
they knew that people's fear of becoming
dope sick that is you know the feeling
of withdrawal that almost every user
describes as like the worst flu times a
hundred that that pretended one hell of
a business model so the cartels start
bringing in heroin heroin and opioid
pills are basically chemical cousins
once you're dicta either one of them
it's the same feeling it produces the
same feeling of euphoria and this
feeling of dependence that you're gonna
be really really sick if you don't get
it if it runs out of your system you're
gonna have diarrhea nausea vomiting
sweats restless leg you're gonna be in a
lot of pain well you mentioned marijuana
and I'm interested in that a little bit
because there have there are some
studies I've looked at which suggests
that when you have either legal medical
marijuana we have more limited
information about legal recreational
because that's rep that's newer
including in my home state of
Massachusetts it appears as though we
have a reduced incidence of opioid
addiction when there is legal medical
marijuana are those studies trustworthy
are there caveats that maybe we're not
getting what's your sense of that
relationship my sense is that it is you
know it's coming out right now it's
developing
there are some conflicting studies but
most of the studies that I've looked at
are in support of it they say that where
it's legal opioids are less likely to be
prescribed and I haven't looked into it
further but I asked that question I was
at a opioid seminar at the University of
Georgia recently there were two scholars
two researchers there and I was like
good bad there like mostly good again I
need to do more research on that myself
so maybe we'll step back a little bit
from the preventing addiction in the
first place and go a little more towards
dealing with addiction where where it
exists what do we know right now about
the different ways in which addiction
should be handled is most effectively
treated right so we know that people
respond to addiction addiction treatment
in different ways and so all all methods
of treatment should be offered I mean I
like to say that the treatment should be
as accessible as the street drugs are
but we know that's far from true only
one in ten people with substance abuse
disorder get any treatment at all and
only one in five who were addicted to
heroin or opioid pills get specialty
treatment so we're not even close to you
know reaching the number of people got
2.6 million Americans addicted right now
some people think it's as high as four
million and if we arrested every drug
dealer we would still have that many
people addicted so what didn't we do all
the evidence supports medication
assisted treatment and that is methadone
and buprenorphine in particular maybe
you've probably heard a methadone going
back to the 70s it was popular after
people came back from Vietnam addicted
but buprenorphine which goes by the
brand name suboxone has also been found
to be really effective and both of these
drugs these m-80s as I call them are
effective at reducing relapse and
overdose and criminal behavior and fifty
to sixty percent of cases as opposed to
abstinence only modalities which are
around ten some people say the last
percent of
now if you talk to people who've gone to
these out-of-state rehabs
abstinence-only and they're doing well
now they are absolutely converts if you
talk to people who have done m80 and
they're doing well their absolute
converts as well but they're less likely
to talk to you on the record because
there's such a stigma around m80
particularly coming from the 12-step
people so I think that's the number one
barrier to turning back this epidemic
the stigma against people who are on m80
many of those that I interviewed in my
book are now like getting their kids
back they're getting their lives
together going to school one woman's
becoming a nurse another was a kid who I
first met when he was just out of high
school and he had taken a job at a
senior living moving company with the
express purpose of stealing people's
pills that's how bad his addiction was
he was a doctor's son he's now getting a
full ride for a ph.d program I mean he's
doing great but it was MIT that allowed
him to get better from that and there's
just I mean there shouldn't be
controversy but because this country
were so entrenched in 12 steps and
abstinence-only and if you take another
drug for a drug addiction you're just
trying to replace one with another that
really holds us back so I just think
more people need to understand the
nuances medication assisted treatment
especially in the law enforcement and
drug court community what about more
thinking about this at the government
level I mean we heard from the current
president that Golden Boy Jared Kushner
I guess during breaks from solving the
israeli-palestinian conflict was going
to deal with the opioid crisis as well I
mean hey what can we say one way or the
other about what the Trump
administration's role has been so far in
dealing with this well president Trump
has said you know we should execute drug
dealers
frankly the drug dealers in my book most
of the drug dealers in the country are
high school former high school athletes
honor roll students tree trimmers
waitresses I mean most users also deal
I'm not I'm not talking about the big
dealer so I'm talking about they're
using their in their deal
to support their using so they won't be
dopesick President Trump said he was
going to declare it a national emergency
he declared it something that sounded
like a natural emergency it's a public
health emergency so it released no new
funds or authority and then the most
recent bill through Congress you know is
did all the right things just not at the
scale that is equal to the crisis right
so all the things like you know going
after fentanyl that's being mail-order
from Hong Kong that's great you know
improving the screening for drug illegal
drugs coming in from the mail and then
but there was a lot of treatment
including some more efforts to beef up
ma tea but it's just tweaking around the
edges of the issue it's not really it's
not like AIDS and HIV which finally you
know after many years because of a lot
of groundswell activism we were able to
make treatment on demand and and lots of
harm reduction
you know syringe exchange services one
of my main characters who sadly was
murdered at the end of the book somebody
ID followed for almost three years you
know she said what we need our urgent
care centers for the addicted urgent
care for the addicted she ironically had
gotten addicted initially at a local
urgent care and because she kept falling
through the gaps in these treatments she
ended up revolving in a world of
criminals and prostitution rings in
order not to get dope sick and when I
went back and I saw that first interview
in November of 2015 she's saying we need
urgent care for the indict it I thought
I mean it just gave me chills because
she was so right and what I see as
urgent care for the addicted is some
national harm reduction strategy where
somebody who's living on the streets can
go to call it a syringe exchange call it
recovery call it a treatment triage
center and they can get access to harm
reduction services like clean needles
hepatitis C HIV treatment and testing
and best of all when they're ready for
it because many people
aren't initially when they're ready for
it then they could get access to
treatment and that's just what we're not
doing a few states have like they have
they'll start ma T in the ER if you
overdose and you end up in the ER so
they have what's called hub-and-spoke
model model where they were foreal
they'll stick with you until you get to
that first appointment it's really great
in those New England states
Massachusetts Rhode Island Vermont are
the ones where we're starting to see a
slight decline in overdose deaths so we
know we know it works
all the studies say it works and now we
have like evidence in certain states
that are applying this and these are
early Medicaid expansion states you know
we still have 14 states that haven't
expanded Medicaid yet so I mean that's
another big thing that we can do and
we're still fighting Obamacare a lot of
what we've been talking about is in Beth
Macy's book dopesick dealers doctors and
the drug company that addicted America
Beth thanks so much for talking to me
about the book
Thank You David really appreciate it